many times in education we teach people
selling this is the problem this is the
solution
and this is one of the unique cases
where this
wasn't the approach but approach was
okay this is a problem
go figure find a way yourself welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
my next guest is one of the most
inspiring entrepreneurs in the israeli
ecosystem
in the cyber ecosystem but in general
meet avi shuwa
ceo and co-founder of orca security avi
is the co-founder and ceo of orca
security he has more than 25 years of
experience in cyber security
and prior to co-founding oroka avi was
the chief technologist at checkpoint
software technologies
and held key positions within unit 8200
of the israeli nsa
while at checkpoint he built and scaled
cyber security solutions that continue
to protect
tens of thousands of organizations to
this day avi believes that cyber
security products should always support
the organization
and not the other way around avishua
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
great thanks for having me i i feel like
i'm
in the orca security offices and it's
really really cool
uh avi i'm excited to talk about your
background thank you for joining me here
your your journey to olga you know i i
can't wait to hear a little bit more
about it and i want you to take me back
all the way
to robotics championship what is that
about
cool so this is definitely an
interesting story and i always give it
as an example when people
ask me when they have a critical
deciding points in their lives
what should they do so they choose age
so they choose b
that the thing that actually affect your
life are moments that you probably never
gave a lot of attention to
and it's a really fun anecdote story but
it's 100
real when i was around the 17 years old
there is the time where as you know
you're about to enlist in the army
you're getting invited to
several tests to join several
opportunities
and i got invited to an opportu to a
test for the israeli intelligence
for some new a course in a
regarding to computing to cyber nobody
even called it cyber event back then
nobody knew about it it was probably the
second
called it wasn't like today that anyone
says okay i'm getting invited to the
screening the 8200 go for that
and i said okay i want to go but at the
robotics championship the same day
so he called the idf ask can it be
rescheduled and told me no this is
unfortunately the last time it can
happen will you able to make it i said
i'm not sure
because the championship is literally
finished 15 minutes before
and it's like 30 minutes drive with the
traffic or should they do
tell me okay if you come you come if you
don't you don't
uh frankly i got her
the traffic was light a day but it was
literally a difference of five minutes
uh if the traffic was slightly tougher
or the champions it was slightly longer
that wouldn't go to the test and my
entire career would be
completely different i i just have to
put things in perspective
here i also took part in this robotics
championship
uh perhaps the most intensive six weeks
any 17 year old can imagine
you're given a challenge in around
december from that moment you have six
weeks to build a fully functioning robot
that can do something as meaningless as
shooting a basketball into a hoop all
the way to playing soccer or solving
challenges and so i can very much relate
that nothing
trump's coming to the championship with
all the excitement
in the nokia stadium and so avi
tell me a little bit about you know
going back to the robotics
what was about that experience that you
think
you know made you want want to be there
so badly so much that you might even
forgo
going to the 8200 unit challenges
so first uh just to put it in
perspective i didn't know what is 8200
and what is this test
all about it wasn't an informed decision
okay i'll pass it but
i think the very nice thing about these
robotics championship and these programs
is that it
allows young children to essentially
become
entrepreneurs in a sense and managers
and to lead projects
because the end of the day for this
robotic championship was
very simple you needed to build a robot
that find a
candle in a maze and put it off and this
is your goal
and this was essentially a go at the
same time
how do you program it what do you build
it from how do you manage that thing
we don't know go figure there's
naturally some mentos but there's no
playbooks unlike
and you know this is one of the things
that i really think that is there
uh that in education are not we don't
put a lot of emphasis off
is that many times in education we teach
people
we're selling this is the problem this
is the solution
and this is one of the unique cases
where this
wasn't the approach but approaches okay
this is a problem
go figure find a way yourself and this
is i think the most
important thing about in this experience
and throughout
the i mean the thing that makes uh you
know israeli startup nation
is that we are very much accustomed to
this approach of
this a problem go find a solution and
not grow search what is the best
solution that was found
out there right right i i completely
agree
and i've been hearing it over and over
again you know it's not just about
the challenges you're presented but it's
the fact that they're so genuine and
innovative in nature that
it very rarely you can rely uh on
previous experiences and so you finish 8
200 and you and
obviously come out of there with a lot
of knowledge and and from what i
for my i gather you know confidence in
this problem-solving mindset
checkpoint you do an incredible things
at checkpoint
uh responsible for much of the
technology and here comes
the new baby orca security right
yes so in fact it's it's been 11 years
i've been 11 years in checkpoint
it wasn't like i went to the army then
did two years and then started my
company
like many do and i think that
the very nice thing that the checkpoint
part was for me is to learn and
understand how businesses works
because in the army you learn very well
technology
you learn how to build technology you
build essentially the muscle
of how to solve large borders you don't
learn how organization works you don't
learn how businesses works it's
extremely different
between the way that you do it in the
army and how
it works in real life and let me give
you an example and always say that i
would never
ever build awk the way that we built it
if i hadn't add my experience into
checkpoint
you know as a technological person
you're presented with a problem for
example the problem is
i want to assess the security of a
system and what is the most
the easiest approach technically go and
install something on it
go and scan it because this is there is
a system go and solve what is the issue
but you need to work in organization to
understand that organization
are a completely more complex beast
that's something that might work when
it's two people with a machine or one
development team doesn't work with
a multi a continent organization that
have hundreds of department that each
one of them
have their own goal agenda you don't
understand how businesses processes
actually work
how friction exists in large
organization
and what actual problems it creates that
are a combination of people technology
and processes
and this is something that there is no
way to learn in my opinion besides
actually seeing working with the people
working with the customers understanding
how their day-to-day life work and then
you can build the technology that
actually solve their problems which
might be
extremely different than what you
envision as someone who's
purely focused on technology right and i
think one of the most amazing gifts
that a unit like the 8200 gives is the
fact that you get to build
products that are incredibly meaningful
and they're
highly secured and they're highly
sensitive yet you don't really have to
deal with a lot of this
product and selling and business stuff
so you you get a gift and then you
you leverage that gift by complementing
it with 11 years at checkpoint
and then you know translating that
technological ability but also
understanding that okay as a leader i
have to be fluent
in this whole world of business i love
that analogy
thank you definitely you know you learn
in the army
very well how to build technology you
learn how to work with people you have
to
add the pleasure of working with
extremely talented people and
solving extremely hard problems but at
the end of the day
in the army of a very simple customer
the customer is internal
there is not a lot of selling and uh
the challenges are very different and in
the real world
and i think that i've seen it in
many cyber security startups that had
extremely great technology
of people that went out of the army and
this was probably the most secured
secure technology out there but they
weren't good in the sense that they
were actually applicable to real-life
situations
and this is important thing because in
real life there is much more compromises
than in a military world and these
compromises are people that have jobs
that needs to do
things and i think that this is the the
success of orca is essentially because
this not
it's not because this is a cool
technology there's a lot of cool
technology out there
but it's a cool technology that solves
friction that allow people you know i
had a customer that told me
you know if i needed to install agent
they needed to coordinate with 300
people across the organization
there's no chance in hell that i'll be
able to do that and
these have security implications because
naturally if you miss
20 then they are not secure if you can
skip that
you save time you save money and you are
more secure and this is something that
might sound a technological person is
something that doesn't make sense what
is the problem going stolen agent so
simple people have been doing agents for
decades so i really believe that this is
the
important combination and frankly one of
the things that
i think happens with the maturity with
the of
the cyber security industry these days
is that more and more businesses are not
from people that have been in this space
that are not just you know
uh people that have been out of the army
just seen cool technology and create
school
cool technology and then with the goal
of exiting and selling the company for
uh several 50 100 million dollar but
actually building meaningful businesses
and i believe that this ever strategic
meaning to israel
because the cyber security industry is
by far one of the fastest growing
industries in the world
and there's absolutely no reason that
israel won't be won't take dramatically
large percent of this and not only by
selling technology to
other phone companies right and and so
orc i believe just a month ago
uh with an announcement of google
leading 210 million dollar series c
and my memory is already fading but i
but i remember the headlines very very
clearly
because it was such a big and we and i
told you this right before we started
it wasn't just you know a orca raising
fund
it's israel the israeli ecosystem
another company that manages
to to raise a substantial amount and be
a dominant player in the world and you
know from
moving from startup nation to to exit
nation to scale up nation and this is i
believe
you know one of the most amazing stories
that we're all so proud of in the
ecosystem and
just creates room for so many more
israeli entrepreneurs to to gain
inspiration
and and what i'm hearing from you is a
lot of that ability was also
translated from the fact that we spent
11 years in checkpoint maturing
business-wise not being hasty with cool
technology but really understanding
what the world needs and that's how you
build a billion dollar company in the
end right
completely and by the way something that
it's important to emphasize
uh okay is we are not one it's not a
one-man show
and it's not one person for not one
founder and we're founded by a group
of eight co-founders that were all
former checkpoint executive and
architect that each one of us brought
different uh skills to the game
and i think that what makes oak clinic
and i you know at the beginning when we
started the company
i didn't unders underestimated by sense
the fact that this is going to be like a
magnet
for an extraordinary number of talented
people
that essentially joined and this is
essentially what allows us to grow
so fast so uh you know people many times
say cool you you raised 200
million dollar in the last round it's
close to 300 million overall
so it's game over but the real answer is
that it's
exactly the opposite this is that's the
beginning with every
investment you're taking a larger
obligation to build the larger company
your investors don't want to at the end
of the day
takings many people
ask me is okay so you talk about
building a large company but the end of
the day when someone offer you you'll
sell the company
and i always say no we're not trying to
but with the latest round i think that
it's more than worth its actions because
we are out of the ranges of any
large player buying orca or not in the
market but
really on a much longer term journey
of building a massive cyber security
company
i love that perspective i think that
you're right when you say that
a lot of people can see the headlines
and say okay well great it's game over
now
they won great now and everything but
you're actually just you're you've
chosen you've opted in
to compete with the with the greatest in
the world and you could have chosen
a different route but you chose to
compete and now the hardest work begins
when you're actually competing with the
best in the world and you're
you're in the big players league and i
just love that eight co-founders
how how does that even how does that
even work
so it works incredibly well and by the
way there is some precedences to that
uh by the way melanox at eight
co-founders
and uh ali i think that alibaba had 18
co-founders and the vast majority of
them are still in the company i think
that the key for that
is a good uh understanding what
everyone brings to the table and it must
be different things
you know i've been a developer of my
most of my career
and i love developing and unfortunately
i haven't fought a single line of golden
orca
on the other end i have amazing
architects that
are leading the development and doing
things that people said that can't be
done before
and they are not leading the management
of the day-to-day business
of course at the beginning it took us i
think some time i think it took us only
a few weeks to
uh for thing to settle and to then who
is doing what
but at the end of the day i believe that
almost the more the merrier
in a sense it's not a one-man show it
can't be a one-man show and
to build strong things you need great
people and it's
better to build to bring them as part of
their coating
i love that so you're starting orca now
you're now in the position of a ceo and
you're a technologist and you realize
that at the end
ceo translates to leadership you know
internal
external 360 degrees like they like to
say
in the army anything surprises you
as you go on this journey to build this
incredible company you know as a leader
then you said wow you know throughout my
years as a developer and a checkpoint
i didn't i didn't realize i'm going to
be confronted with this challenge
so uh one thing that is more it's not my
first leadership poll though
i managed a large organization also
before so
while i the passion of technology it's
not my
first opportunity managing now the thing
about managing in a startup
which is both challenging and exciting
is at the end of the day
unlike even high level management in the
company
you are responsible for everything
literally everything there is no one
else
and but there are also no boundaries
in a sense you are making your own
boundaries and this
is extremely exciting and
because nothing prevents you need to you
own everything but there is nothing that
prevents you from taking it
to whatever path you wish for example
i am a big believer i'll give an example
of something that
i'm not sure if you saw that happened us
when we were thinking about marketing
i'm not sure if you are going to the
website of cyber security companies from
time to time but when they do
one of the things that i sometimes see
is that even though i'm in this
industry for more than a two decades i
can go
see the first page of the company and
understand what they do
we go i've done this experiment with
many companies where i just
put two minutes into seeing the first
page of the company and they still don't
understand what they do
i thought i was the only one that feels
that way i'm going to know
you can and even if you understand what
they do you don't understand
why their solution why they believe that
their solution is better than the
competition not if you should believe it
but why they
claim that their solution is better than
the industry
and i'm not a big marketing expert but
said okay
at the end of the day now are my
customers so let's present them with
facts let's and we learned something
that i was a big believer in
that i don't think that they've seen any
other startup do which essentially we
call the punch out i didn't
i hired someone who is not a marketing
person but a technologist that simply
created lab and installed the
competitors and our solution in same
environment and recorded it in 10
minutes youtube video now people told me
you are mad nobody is going to see 10
minute videos
you know it's too long for martin said
but if i'm a practitioner and i can see
10 minutes video instead of putting a
month
trying to test is probably a good roi
and people told me you know but
competition will
uh usually will block it legally which
they tried
but we decided to go for that because
they believed that the market
loved it and this is something that
would be
almost impossible to run in a large
company i won't say impossible but
almost impossible but in a startup you
can take this approach and simply do
that
or uh and i can give numerous more
examples where you can get an amazing
results
when you just don't go and do the
standard thing that everyone is doing
and this is the thing that excites the
everyday thing just think about the best
approach and not
try to say okay what is the playbook for
that because bigger organizations are
good in playbooks and startups good in
finding the best solutions
i love that avi thank you so much for
coming i really appreciate it
i have a few last questions for you are
you ready
of course all right we'll start off easy
your favorite subject in school
kindergarten to 12th grade
in fact philosophy i had assistance
learning philosophy and i am a major in
both computer science and
philosophy wow okay i love that
one of your role models professional or
personal
so in fact i don't really love this uh
question because i don't believe in role
models in a
uh you know i think there's a lot of
people that have learned a lot of things
but
there is no one person say okay is my
role model everything
i really think that you should see learn
good ideas
but don't try to follow a certain person
i think that's one of the best answers i
got for this question and the last
question
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself or if i were to ask
anybody who is avishua
what would they say so
i believe first is not a good riven i am
the least a good driven person and i'm
extremely analytical
i don't believe in a a gut feeling
and i'm a big believer in me in people
in the team
i'm a big believer in teamwork and not
about
being a one-man show i love that so we
have
not ego driven we have teamwork and what
was the last one
extremely analytical i'm not a big i'm
not believer in gut feeling
you know i've i'll give an example i'll
i don't really trust my judgment in
interviews mostly i really prefer to see
data exam
results or not okay i feel that these
guys strong or not
right i i love that and uh you know at
the end
i can only imagine the journey that one
has to go through
you know starting a company bringing it
to what it is today after all and
holding the position of the ceo and
constantly understanding the implication
of the decisions you're making
that perhaps in the beginning they're
more for the team and for project market
fit but
now they're across a wide range of
constituents that have different
incentives and i can only imagine the
struggles but we're going to have to
leave
that to another episode avi toda thank
you very very much
and stay safe and stay healthy and best
of luck with orca security is just
amazing
thank you so much thanks for having me
stay safe
you